Jamie smooth with Rob Gronkowski oh the
grunt baby cut meat that's a tough
question for sure in the big game we've
seen it happen against the Giants yes
right but we've seen the other way
around
against the field yes God's got him they
both hurt oh it's only week a party at
the boat we don't mean dumping
everything on all right that means I
guess so oh man you crazy crazy oh good
question though come on now plenty of
times you know this is the first season
I've seen in a long time yes well I felt
like it was parody well I felt like you
didn't know who was gonna go through the
big game even before the playoff started
people were losing people who are parody
the games are tight this is the first
season in a long time where even some of
the smaller markets yes had a team they
root for
it was crazy this is like that's why I'm
kind of nervous about this game cuz you
don't know it's the matchup thing it's
the coach thing yes it's a lot of versus
going on in this game well and this is
also this coach yeah you know yeah this
is also reason why I like having you as
the Rich Eisen show media correspondent
JB Smoove is because you're maybe on
unsuspectingly treading on ground that
Gronk
doesn't want to tread on the thigh
meaning when you say losing in a
completely crazy manner he was the one
who blew the tackle on the Miami miracle
there you go hey lost in a crazy bizarre
manner he thought you might have been
referring to that got questions you
didn't ask
oh yeah I said you want me to read them
out read about okay okay
questions that JB Smoove could not get
to it last night's media night James
white you were gonna say this you're so
quiet and unassuming I almost forget
you're on the team is it true that
during a season you once disappeared
from the team for four weeks to take
your family on a Disney cruise and no
one on the Patriots notice
he's a captain too nobody even though
he's a captain it's a captain he plays
like a few dollars a game that's so I
thought you who notices who note when
he's not other Belichick is Tom Tom
Brady I mean think about that play lat
in the last game when Brady thought
about running for the he thought oh I
mean I'm gonna run for the first down
and open up he saw a D Ford backed up
and just pulls a rabbit out of a hat but
back shoulder at the jeans white but
when watching film just the other day
I'm so impressed with James White's
blitz pickup mmm-hmm
like everybody knows he's a great
receiver back till he brings all the you
know he can run the football you know
he's got great vision he is a really
good pass protect you know where you
learned how to pass protect like that on
the Disney cruise for weeks
what else you gonna do exactly under why
I mean there's Mickey Mouse yes there's
lilo there's stitch and then there's
blitz pickup yep puto
yeah and goofy yeah I got a question do
they have roller coasters on Disney
Cruise no come on
be silly there's no rides here's one for
Robert Woods you're from Gardena
California and played at USC so you're
qualified to answer this bigger event
for LA football the Rams coming to town
or Jeff Fisher leaving go hard go hard
sometimes look at him
great I don't think anybody's ever made
the Super Bowl going seven and nine
there you go
or six and ten right right Aqib Talib
you're a notoriously aggressive player
last time you were in a Super Bowl you
committed a vicious facemask penalty was
fined $26,000 my question is what
violent penalty are you looking to do
this time helmets a helmet horse collar
or the classic wet willy through the ear
hole under it please I hate that they
just go to flag on that I can see them
doing the wet willy that's a fifteen six
thousand dollar fine that explains why
he's stealing people's chains now how to
make up for it let's make up for it you
can ask us if both kickers oh yeah you
couldn't get to the kickers last oh man
it was crazy
couldn't get home couldn't get to to uh
pecker - heck no no this is kicker on
the ball case said Greg the laser line
Gostkowski okay and guess Ison's foot
what do you guys think of the proposed
overtime rule that would call for a
sudden death where each kicker gets to
kick the other in the groin until one
gives up perfect are you kidding me how
would that work can you walk me through
what the real power how is that what
would that look like JB you go flood you
both stand in front of each other when
it did it going twice
point was that okay the first one go on
in these so that sounds like a beavis
and butt-head sketch so you do you toss
the coin at all see who goes first
that's a crucial that you're putting
more on the coin toss than ever before
man and and you also can pass it you
know is there a recovery the most
outrageous thing we can write this is
great last one on that subject yeah you
were a tails never fails you call heads
every time what are you JP oh I like I
like I like tails
I'll go tails okay you know other two
okay I do amazingly both teams that won
the coin toss called heads for the Super
Bowl when and yeah both won the Rams
called heads and it came up tails and
that's how the the rant the Saints got
the ball last one Jared golf this is a
physical bit set up by saying that
apparently you didn't have the
opportunity to fully illustrate for
Jared exactly what he meant by your
question what does that mean you know
what I asked him very clearly I said
look you guys are the Rams you're doing
against a goat and Tom Brady oh he
thought what he thought I was talking
about like Tom Brady to go and I was I'm
saying how does a ram beat a goat
he thought I was talking about the goat
Tom Brady what's on my real goat how
about a ram be to go you buckle you
buckle that's the only way they both
have horns but a ram is of course bigger
there's only way a ramp beat a goat so I
told him use as a metaphor for this game
[Laughter]
[Applause]
doesn't work you have the two kickers
come out and it's gonna be what if they
win the game yeah that's gonna be the
headline Rams buck Patriots go go go go
go go JB smoothes work from last night
at the how do you beat a goat how does
the RAM beat ago man I don't think I
look on National Geographic for that one
I don't know all right all right I
appreciate your RAM beats I'm gold
Thank You Billy go thank you way to
commit you get that but he could serve
version of it but you didn't get totally
anyway I couldn't like cuz you didn't
like you didn't couldn't explore it was
rich it was the whole tell me on the
floor
it was really hard to walk insane
Timmy's be packed I found my way through
Wow do we get to the crowd where Willy's
that was you I thought that was you Juba
get away it was me baby I do and if that
doesn't work really the open path myself
right through your groin kick if that's
what oh well that's less extreme that's
last resort yeah I'll do that at the
Brady at the Brady port it's only for
overtime by the way that would just be
[Music]
the show in a minute with j-b 2019 tour
dates you're back on the road in Seattle
we just talked all about Seattle
starting on March 1st in San Francisco
March 2nd the 2019 tour what's the name
of your tour a lot of gagging tour the
love this moving aimlessly through life
no stress no pressure you know okay
that's in March and people can can get
tickets by going on pretty much every
j.b smoove calm Louis Houston DC the
Warner Theatre in Washington DC
fun it'll be great all you got you got
lollygaggin okay thank you
I'm a whole something special for you
here we go okay I got my lollygaggin
tour shirt so there's my pretty face on
there let's go I got my over logo and
everything I'm home logo logo hideous
mine is my keyword you plan your
destination and provides your journey
that plays football
yeah yeah I like this
yeah the creme de la creme de la creme
but again Oh sooner do Kalyan sir oh
gosh book of Leon's shirt Oh people can
get this at JB Smoove calm if they can't
and also on my Instagram today that's
the Leon don't cover and then the back
he ain't wrong you just ain't right this
is awesome I can't wait to rock these
MIT oh come on man this is what it's all
about man getting out there making
people laugh man I appreciate what you
allow me to do oh thank you the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience